I am here
Just on another shore
Always in your corner
Watching you soar
Unbreakable bonds,
that's what we've got.
Family takes care
of family, right?
See, you get it.
Wait. I got a great idea.
You should come
live with me in Florida.
Yeah, we're going
home tomorrow.
Come on. Get in the bag.
Wait, wait, Vivo,
where are you going?
Are you worried about where
you'll go to the bathroom?
It's OK.
I got wipes in here.
Oh, the weird kid.
Gabi, what are you doing?
Just playing a tune.
Look what I got.
Are you excited
about today?
Oh, yeah, of course.
What's today?
It's your first cookie sale
with the Sand Dollar Troop.
Woot! Woot!
Yeah, I don't think
that's gonna happen.
I've taken the Sand Dollars
about as far as I can.
Gabi, what are you
talking about?
You've only been
to one meeting.
I know,
but it's time to move on.
Move on?
You just started
with the troop.
You're still getting
to know them.
Tail never fails.
Please, give them a chance.
Look, I made
my resignation video.
Cookies!
Peace. We out. Bye!
Creative.
Wait, wait, wait.
This is the best part.
I turned them
into zombie clowns.
Buy my cookies.
You can't keep
pushing everyone away.
If you don't at least try to
get along with other kids,
you're going
to be very lonely.
Meh.
Gabriela, escúchame,
you're doing this.
I let you keep that--
that-- that purple hair.
You owe me one!
But Mum, all they ever talk
about are selling cookies,
getting badges,
saving the Everglades.
It's so boring.
You're going
to the cookie sale,
you're going
to take selfies,
and you're going
to have fun and bond!
Now put on the uniform!
It's really cute.
Vivo! You're here!
Yup. And now I'm leaving.
You followed me, didn't you?
And you snuck in my bag
because you love me!
I'm so glad
you're here, Vivo.
Now I have someone to share
my friendship bracelet with.
-Best friends forever!
-Hey, let go!
-Paws to yourself.
-Hold still.
Forever's a long time, kid.
I have a song to deliver.
Nice meeting you. Peace.
Are those
little gravestones?
Oh, that's my petting zoo.
Well, it was.
-Gabi.
-It's my mum. Hide!
Hernández!
Oh, hello, blonde one.
Other girls.
Gabi, where's your uniform?
Yes, we have rules,
Hernández.
Only a Sand Dollar
in full uniform
may participate
in a cookie sale.
What?
The cookie sale's today?
I totally thought
that was yesterday.
But you didn't show up
yesterday either, did you?
That's a good point.
I was busy
rescuing this animal.
What are you doing?
Oh, he's so cute!
Can I pet him?
-No.
-Go to town. He loves it.
Look at that face.
-He's adorable.
-Hey. Stop.
This is borderline abuse.
-His little ears.
-So fuzzy. What's his name?
His name's Vivo.
We have totally
different definitions
of the word "plan".
To me,
and other rational people,
a plan revolves
around the five Ps.
"Proper planning
prevents poor performance."
But you,
your plans
are just bad impulses.
What are you doing?
Ta-da!
Sometimes
you gotta improvise.
Yeah, that will never float.
And the journey begins now!
It floats.
It actually floats.
Heads up!
Give me a sec.
Don't wanna pull a hammy.
OK. Ready, Vivo?
And she missed.
I missed the boat
completely.
Did you see that, Vivo?
Hysterical.